standee I'm John Stansfield from Troop
121 Columbia Missouri we're at the world
chess Hall of Fame and the Chess Club
scholastic center of st. Louis today's
event we have both the Great Rivers
Council and the greater st. Louis area
Council as they're playing a big game of
chess with each other with with a live
chess board chess mayor badge is being
launched today nationally and we're real
excited to have it happen here in the
state of Missouri where the first 20
Scouts who have had an opportunity to go
through the requirements will be earning
that or have earned a badge and will
receive the badge today and part of the
ceremonies so it's a great way to
celebrate scouting to recognize some
boys for learning a new skill and to
welcome the world chess Hall of Fame to
st. Louis our astronaut from NASA Greg
Chamitoff
we are going to first before you get to
hear him speak he went to outer space on
the shuttle number 134 in April and he
played a game against Earth he was white
and earth was black they played 22 moves
and at the end of the game he landed and
they had to vote on who won
well Earth said they won I wasn't so
sure
so Jennifer Shehadeh who's a former US
Women's Champion and a commentary for
tonight along with Yasser Arafat a
four-time US chess champion will be
finishing the game so we'll do the first
22 moves and then they will come up with
a real ending not the voted ending so I
even I don't know how it's going to go
the teams are two councils white is
Great Rivers Council which I'm
affiliated with 33 counties in
mid-missouri black is is great greater
st. Louis area council
so maybe games begin the boys in my
troop were among the first in the nation
there in the chess merit badge their
merit badge counselor was Jean Singh
felled and she did a wonderful job when
they earned it they have to know the
etiquette of chess for example shake
your partner's hand before and after the
game they have to know chess notation
we need to see three history critical
thinking had a problem solving when
you're in a difficult position how to
get out of it and I sort of thing
I'll see you try to put yourself in a
better position so you can come out on
top instead of having a bad all the way
up all the time so just interesting way
different ways to think about things
different strategies and thought
processes they have to play three games
that they know tape and then at the end
they go over that with their merit badge
counselor and tried to determine what
went right and what went wrong they do
an after-action review of the chess game
chess is with your mind your brain power
and he actually takes talent and skill
and hard study well today they're kind
of learning what the fundamentals the
chest is all about
you know the strategic thinking the it's
more than just the game of chess they're
learning how to think for themselves how
to think ahead but to work together just
it's just a great day of some
camaraderie and and some fun here with
scouting my name is Greg sham it's off
and I just got back from the space
shuttle mission sts-134 I was in scouts
as far as long as I can remember so I
was in Cub Scouts as a kid I grew up in
Montreal Canada and so as a Cub Scout
there and then moved to California
eventually and joined Scouts there and
was the scouts sort of all the way so
but it took me right till the end to
finish my Eagle like the last thing I
did probably like a month before turned
18 so it's an honor to be here and to be
part of this being in like a living
chess and seeing a video of someone
who's actually been in space and that
was really that was just really amazing
to see while the Boy Scouts it does have
a strong outdoor program we also have a
strong academics program and of course
just fits nicely into that well you know
four kids were playing chess I would
tell them the joint Scouts and four kids
that were in scouts I would tell them to
learn chess it fair for everybody you
know I'd encourage them to do both these
things obviously you know and the thing
is there's a lot to have in common I
mean these things these things you know
help kids develop skills you know I
think people have to set their own
standards and and and go for it and
believe that things can really happen I
mean you know I didn't know that I was
gonna get to fly in space when I was a
kid but I believed it somehow and you
know I think believing in yourself and
and being persistent and setting your
own standards which you really have to
do to be successful so this is what I
would tell them it's such a great thing
for scouting you know we just celebrated
a hundred years we just were now we're
starting our second hundred years of
scouting and what a great way to kick it
all off right here in the downtown st.
Louis the twenty Scouts that earned the
badge will receive their badges from
Greg Chamitoff he's an Eagle Scout and
an astronaut with NASA took a chessboard
I put up space and actually played the
game up there and he's here with us
today to celebrate this great event
as soon as I heard that I was going to
be awarded by an astronaut the first in
the nation my mouth to open okay you
know in terms of you know being
successful in life and trying to
accomplish your dreams you know I think
it's really important for people to do
their best you know it's a no to find
something they're passionate about and
then to work really hard at it what's
what's the next move what if this what's
the next move I make in life what's the
next move I'm making a chess game